good morning everyone if you are
following us on Twitter and and wish to
make comments the hashtag is why do d
2014 that's why do d 2014 and i hope you
will comment throughout the day so again
my name is Susan Gibbons and i am the
university librarian and it's my great
pleasure to welcome you those of you who
are here physically in the room and i
know we have many of you who are joining
us online and we appreciate that you
were able to join us today this is the
second yale day of data and this emerged
as a result of a workshop that three
members of the yale community
participated in at karas from university
IT Michelle Hudson who you just saw and
Jill partek from the library they
attended a national East Science
Institute and as a part of that
Institute's workshop they were asked to
go around campus and interview faculty
and interview administrators about
questions around data and one of their
findings was that there was a disconnect
let's say between the two that on the
one hand administration thought that
that faculty and scientists were quite
satisfied with how they are handling
their data and on the side of the
scientists and the faculty there was a
sense of there could be more services
there could be more assistance more help
in that area and we wish that Yale would
provide it so we decided to put together
this conference with the help of all of
our partners because we wanted to start
a dialogue on campus we wanted to bring
attention to the importance of data
we've always been using data but the
role of it now has increased the scope
the scale the complexity has gotten much
deeper and we hope now that we're can
see that there's truly a community of
users on campus and perhaps collectively
together we can solve some of the
problems that we're currently facing
whether it's a tsunami of data a tidal
wave or whatever however terminology
would like to use so I'm very glad to
say that our day of data will be begun
with our keynote speech
Ben [ __ ] who is our University
Provost he's also the William Bernard
professor of economics and I wish to
thank him personally for joining us
again in the second year and kicking off
our day of data then so thanks for being
here and thank you Susan especially for
your leadership here and learn and
others for helping organize this and
working so hard on this I'm very pleased
that the Provost office is co-sponsoring
this event this is as Susan said the
second annual day of data and the
response to this has been tremendous a
hundred and twenty people registered to
attend the event and the demand was so
great there's another hundred and sixty
people on the waitlist which I think
probably indicates just how much
interest is in data around campus and as
Susan said the events are being
live-streamed I have to say I've never
been on Twitter before I don't know that
means I was going a little bit
intimidated by that it is what a
fuddy-duddy am as we did last year
there's gonna be a bunch of Yale faculty
presenting talks about that of data
intensive research and talking about how
they navigate the problems the
challenges associated with curating and
stewarding data yelled had some exciting
development in this area in the past
year one of which I mentioned actually
last year which is the new census
research data center and the leading
force behind that peach shot will be
presenting later on in the day I'm
pretty excited to see that getting up
and running because it's been a long
history going back to my time as chair
of economics when I get that to happen
and it is now happening we're also going
to talk about the Yale open data access
project at the School of Medicine I
wanted just to talk a little bit about
how important data is becoming in
research data is changing the way in
which not only we do research but the
way in which we approach research in
general and this is fairly well
understood in the sciences and the
social sciences I think at this point I
mean big data has become a bit of a
cliche in fact sometimes I don't quite
know what the borders between big data
and small data but it will understand
that some
important we understand university-wide
at Yale that things like computational
biology and biostats are incredibly
important in the future of what we do in
the life sciences but it goes beyond
that so I me an example from the law
school which is a possibly apocryphal
story there was a lecture here maybe 18
months ago a highly empirical highly
data-intensive lecture in the law school
and as people were going out one of the
slightly more I'm being live streams
lepre shouldn't said but if he said
anyway slightly more fuddy-duddy law
school professors complained to the
person he was walking out with it was a
he I'm not giving away too much there
that this talk had asked no new
questions this very empirical talk had
asked no new questions and this was
meant to be a criticism and the reply he
got was yeah it didn't answer any new
questions but it answered a bunch of old
questions and that truly is the point
that there are things we can do with
data we can ask new questions with data
but we can also for the first time our
answer questions that have been
speculated about for decades we're
learning in and the humanities and the
social sciences that things that we used
to answer with anecdotes look very
different when we apply data and in fact
the things we thought were the answers
turn out to be wrong so these questions
about how to handle big data that are
well-known in the sciences a little
known in the social sciences are going
to affect all of us and we're seeing
this right across campus extending
mentioned to law school but to the
digital humanities projects as well that
susan has been a big leader in they do
raise new problems and it will have time
to talk about some of those problems
today the first day of data was primal
it primarily about internal
collaborations at Yale the way of people
here at Yale are addressing
cross-disciplinary challenges of working
with data and this year we're expanding
this view to look at collaborations that
extend beyond Yale collaborations with
in and with industry government and
other academic institutions we've a
number of people visiting
today from other institutions in
Connecticut and Beyond and a warm
welcome to all of you we also have to
visiting speakers joining us Philip
Bourne is the Associate Director for
data science at the National Institute
of Health and he will talk about
initiatives at the institutional state
and federal levels and Cathy O'Neill is
director of the lead program at the
Columbia School of Journalism and she
recently wrote the very popular book
doing data science she will address the
cultural aspects of data which has
different meanings for different people
today's program reflects the year that
2014 it has been the year of big data
not only in universities but in the
public sector as well the rising
awareness of the issues surrounding data
policy have been very much an evidence
here on campus and at the institutional
level we're responding to this a number
of ways in particular with various
advisory committees meeting right now to
look at some of the key questions to
address at a recent conference of
Provost I was out a couple of weeks ago
I'm finding that similar committees are
forming right across the country there
are new regulatory issues to worry about
there are issues about the new
compliance we have to do with data
coming from public funding agencies for
research so I'm very pleased this is not
a one-off event but the start of a
series of programs involving Yale
faculty postdocs and students that will
continue throughout the year and we hope
with this day of data is going to be an
annual event I'm very grateful you being
here today and I encourage you all you
to be involved in the year ahead I I
don't want to hog the floor here i think
what i'm going to do his stop and allow
people to ask questions either of me or
of len or Susan but I might first just
ask Leonard Susan if they have any
comments they want to hear all right so
I think I want to focus my comments on
what some people might be wondering is
why exactly is the library involved in
data and why is the library pushing this
question because in many ways the
traditional view of libraries is the
physical book and yet here we are
co-sponsoring an event on data and the
answer to that question is a shift that
we're seeing very much within the
library world which is
is moving beyond just the care of the
physical collections and moving upstream
in many ways in the research process so
traditionally libraries were involved in
collecting the end result of research
which was often in the form of a book or
a journal article and bringing that to a
campus so that others could build upon
that knowledge what we're seeing now
though is that the same skills that
librarians have been applying to that
process can now be applied to the
research much sooner an example being as
you go out for your grants you're often
being asked and you will increasingly be
asked to create a data management plan
to submit with that grand that plan will
ask you how are you going to store your
data how are you going to arrange it how
are you going to curate it preserve it
how are you going to make sure others
who need access to it can identify it
find it and use it that is what
libraries do we have been curating and
collecting and preserving and helping
people 26 discover and gain access to
information all along now we can start
to help doing it in a very different
realm which is with data but in order
for this to happen I think the
librarians need to be involved earlier
in the process almost as soon as the
grant writing happens and we now have on
our staff to data librarians who are
available to work with you to create
that data management plan so that when
you're ready to submit you have some
guidance on how to do that and we don't
work with in a vacuum we are working
with other data librarians across the
country who are familiar with the
requirements and the growing
requirements of those federal funding
agencies so as you can see it's the same
skills we've had all along but we're
trying to apply them now in a very
different way to help all of you in your
research and i hope you will through
this conference and through
conversations with us start to see the
role that the library can play with you
and we welcome being one of your
collaborators we welcome being someone
who can join you in this process and it
will be our job to
to bring to that conversation an
understanding of the resources that are
available to you from Yale whether from
University I TS from high performance
computing from the other institutes and
centers and perhaps we can be that
networking function perhaps we can be
that node on campus that is aware of
what others are doing and to say that
what you're trying to accomplish has
similarities has patterns that we see in
other research that's going on and we
can perhaps be the ones to help you come
together and think about collaboration
in ways that you might not be aware of
because it's so difficult to move across
the silos of the university so library
support the entire university and we
move across all disciplines so it will
leverage that cross-disciplinary nature
of the libraries for the support of your
own research to help define those
colleagues those who can help you and we
can hopefully also build a community of
practice the intellectual powerhouse of
Yale is incredible and as you struggle
with your questions your methodologies
or even how to store my data and how to
do it in different ways again perhaps
the library can be that source that will
help you find others who can think about
the problem with you that we can be the
collaborators and the glue that brings
it all together so I wanted to take that
opportunity to make that pitch because
it is a very different way of thinking
about libraries but it's one that we are
now well positioned to serve that role
we're ready to hang out our shingle and
say come to us with your data questions
and I hope you'll take that is an
invitation to contact us and now I'll
turn it over to line
good morning everyone how's everyone
doing today everybody seems kind of
quiet that's okay so first of all thank
you to all the organizers who put this
day together right it really is a
fantastic event on campus and it
probably is the thing that's going to be
the catalyst to really move us forward
because at the end of the day when you
think about what it's going to really
take to move things forward its people
so I'm sure you know the CIO is here in
front of the room and probably the thing
you're kind of wondering is what great
technology am I going to talk about and
I would love to do that but I don't
think this is necessarily the forum to
get into all the details suffice it to
say there's a fair amount of things
going on with NIT that are very exciting
particularly in the area of high
performance computing we've been
expanding our capability in that space
I'm very pleased to announce that in
partnership with faculty on campus we've
received our second NSF grant for cyber
infrastructure our first grant was
approximately five hundred thousand
dollars to implement a science Network
very high speed network 100 gigabit
network that connects our major labs on
campus to our high-performance computing
clusters that's very exciting and our
recent grant is approximately eight
hundred thousand dollars again awarded
through the NSF and that's going to
allow us to put some new technology in
that's going to increase the efficiency
of the network it's a technology called
software-defined networking and we're
working very closely with computer
science department on the implementation
of that technology so we're going to
continue to build out infrastructure
we're growing in other spaces as well
we're growing in the space of security
and privacy so as we think about some of
the high performance computing
continuing to work in areas like
genomics and bioinformatics we're
actually looking at ways that we can put
in high performance computing capability
that's HIPAA compliant so we can we can
deal with the privacy issues and the
regulatory issues we have around data so
you'll continue to hear more and more
and more
about those things so I was asked
actually to respond to some of the
comments then was talking about so first
of all don't let the man fool you he's
not a fuddy-duddy he's a very highly
sophisticated a technology user I know
at first hand the and he's very much
like many other faculty and researches
on campus that have great demands of
Technology one of the things that Ben
did say is this notion of answering old
questions and answering new questions
and and I wanted to respond to that by
saying sometimes we don't even know what
the new question is and and and the
capability we now have with big data
conceptually we're starting to look into
areas where we're looking at a
predictive modeling of big data sets
we're looking at prescriptive analytics
and data that can start to find new
discoveries and answer the questions
before you know what the question
actually is so how we continue to do
that we're looking at ways to implement
technology like data visualization
clearly you know big data is a is a very
popular term and I often ask people what
they think big data actually is but it's
to me it's just simply it's something
that just takes too long to process if
it's if it's if you can't move it store
it process it manage it preserve it it's
probably too big and that's the problem
sometimes we have data that's too big
and it is an arms race we continue to
try and grow our infrastructure to deal
with it but I think the real challenge
is going to be how we think about using
the data what capabilities do we have
and what new technologies can we
implement so I t continues to grow and
evolve in the last several years we've
been building a stronger unit within the
organization we're currently searching
for senior director of research
technology and the exciting thing about
that position is that we're partnering
with the Provost office and the Dean the
deputy Dean of medicine and what we're
doing
a is imagining the creation of our
Senate for research computing on campus
something that didn't exist before and
why is this so important I think it's
important because you know again at the
top of the pyramid how we get at solving
some of these problems is really about
people and putting the right people in
place to start to work together and
build communities across campus there's
lots of benefits of bringing various
disciplines together to solve common
problems whether they're common
algorithms common programs that they can
share or just have a place to go and
communicate and work with their
colleagues on some of the things that
the they are trying to solve so I'm
really excited about some of the changes
going on in IT really excited about the
partnerships that we're building on
campus and I'm really excited that the
you know their this about this
collaboration that's been formed between
i TS the library and other Institute's
on campus to start to focus on some of
the big challenges around data so again
thank you for having me here today and
any questions Cathy up hold on
microphone right in front no all right
hello yes okay so I'm really excited
about the librarian as the sort of the
data manager or like consultant of data
management and one of the things that it
strikes me is like really really needed
for a lot of people I I talked to who
use data is this concept of
anonymization and in particular d
anonymization so for example I was
talking to a startup that is kind of
surveillance in New York City and they
didn't understand because i was a little
bit worried about people you know the
privacy and they told me oh this is not
going to be a problem because we're
going to open source all the data
and I was like no that's not what you do
so it there seems to be like a real lack
of understanding of what it means to D
anonymize so-called anonymized data
sources I know this is just one of many
many different things but one thing
that's exciting to me about the idea of
the librarians role is that they there's
at least a person who's sort of like in
charge of making sure that the data
users are informed about this kind of
issue and it's it's one where I think
the one way we can move forward I hope
we move forward is sort of in data
classification and that classification
says with this data this is what can be
used I think what will happens right now
is we each sort of come up with our own
classification scheme we have a sense in
our mind how the data can be used and
reused by others but we aren't able to
convey it in a way that makes sense to
everyone else so if we can start to
think about what are you know the five
levels or six levels that reflect things
such as the reused ability the
anonymization of the material the the
privacy the protection that has to be
there then it ends in the librarians
mind it ends up being a metadata field
it ends up being a classification that
we express as we index that data but
first we need that classification system
for us to then apply it and privacy for
librarians is an issue that has always
been on our mind and there's there's
many federal laws and state laws that
require us to protect you know if you're
circulating a book no one can can know
what books you're using so for us that
that's something that we've always been
on the forefront of our mind and I think
we can apply to it but in order for it
to work we need some standardization and
standards is another area where
libraries are have have been at the
forefront of creating national
international standards so we can
communicate without having to pick up
the phone to say with this data set you
can do the following things and so I
think you're right to point out that
there's classifications and other things
that we can be applying to the data
other questions or come
it's for me or for bed yes sir hold on
we have a mic coming over to you thank
you thank you and I'm an epidemiologist
who is on the edge of retirement and as
I think back over my career I've got
massive datasets sitting on holic Yale
sitting on either very large now brittle
tapes or floppy disks that nothing can
read so it's a very practical question
about actually how do we physically
store these these data sets now let
alone make them available to everybody
else which we want to do but it's just
it's just a very self I've I've not
found an answer to this problem yeah it
is my favorite topic vendo this is my
favorite topic because digital
preservation is an area that I'm trying
to bring a lot of attention to so you're
the problem you are describing is a
problem that's we see in many different
fields so for example when the by Nikki
library receives the papers of a great
writer what we receive our boxes with
papers and then floppy disks audio tapes
every kind of format you can imagine so
we've built up a digital forensics lab
within the library to help us either
emulate what was the operating system
the software and the computer to try to
get that data off or two if we're lucky
enough we actually get the parts and we
reconstruct with that computer was so
there's actually groups on campus who
are thinking about the digital
preservation problem which I think then
connects very nicely to your question
which is I now have content regardless
of what the content is a manuscript or
if it's data that needs to make it to
the next generation and how do we think
about what activities we can do today to
either catalog that it exists it's in
this format to get from you as much
knowledge as we can about the data so
that when you are have retired and
you're no longer on campus to help us
we have enough information to try to do
our best job in stewarding that data to
the next generation I'll be over the
next week all right maybe Len I have
comments on that as well I would just
add to that that you know that I I think
as we continue to evolve we'll sort to
see technology that will kind of fill in
some of the some of the middle space
there so so clearly preservation
curation or some some some very key
things but we need to start to build
platforms that have the capability of
ingesting high volumes of this data
across the institution so we have a
question of ingestion or the creation of
the data I think we have a question of
storage we're going to store that and
not have people necessarily think about
some of the some of the typical things
that you would want to do with data like
you know after a certain amount of time
maybe you want to move it to less
expensive type storage devices maybe you
want to archive it somewhere else
opposed to you know very expensive fast
running disks so so we have the the
ingestion to capture we have overall
management on an ongoing basis I think
we'll need to continue to work in that
space and then last piece is
dissemination and I think you know new
technologies that's going to give us the
ability to actually take some of this
curated data some of this data that's
being preserved and make it available to
the world I think that space in between
is also an important place where
technology is going to play a big role
hi Amy justice I'm from the medical
school one of the things that I think
needs to be considered in this
discussion that hasn't been mentioned
yet is the whole roll of the human
investigations committee IRB review
because typically when one puts in a
proposal one is asked to say when
they're going to destroy the data and
the feeling is that that's a protection
for the patients were involved in the
study so that comes in direct conflict
with with the goals that you were
expressing and not to mention the goals
of many investigators who are very
nervous about destroying data for all
the reasons that you might think of so I
would just suggest that I think it's
very important that I RB leadership and
national leadership really in terms of
how I arbys are set up and what they are
expected to do must participate in these
discussions or once again the
investigator is going to be put in
between the two groups who are telling
the very different things I don't
whether to respond to say I don't think
that we've sorted out nationally where
we are on this we've got this real
tension between IRB and HIPAA on the one
side privacy right because the first
question alluded to and the wish to make
data available and to preserve date LOL
to reproduce results and so on and i
don't i'm not be honest I'm not that
confident we're going to end up in a
good place I am again this is maybe
eight I don't mean Yale and I'm a good
place i mean the nation in a good place
I think that these tensions between
privacy rights and and access are real
tensions and in some sense the history
of the IRB the history of the human
subjects law and practice in the US
doesn't fill me with enormous confidence
right i mean we've kind of grouped
towards procedures and we kind of know
how to do them and then we will copy
each other and we're looking around what
we do with this case we go and see what
whatever Florida State did last week or
last year and so on and
I don't think any of us think maybe I'm
wrong with okay but I don't I'm yet to
meet somebody who thinks that we arrived
at where we've arrived at with IRB rules
by really sitting down and saying how
should this be so we end up with
over-regulation in some places and
possibly insufficient privacy regulation
and others so I my worry here is we will
see this will see that historical
process that sort of accumulated
regulation and law without necessarily
thinking it through abstract game saying
what we should do I think we may see
that occur again in this area I it it's
it's a frustration for many researchers
the tension between privacy and big data
that and just what has to be private if
we if we if we apply the full IRB
standards to some of these large data
sets then we end up doing what we all
have to do this morning which is sign of
former saying well that was it okay to
see our faces on TV which which my gut
feeling says at some point in time is
over regulation and sump at some point
some part of me says we're really going
to live in a society where we can't have
a discussion with with broadcaster
Twitter without ever having to fill in a
form as that seems a pity but I fear
that this this isn't going to end up in
a great place but it isn't just going to
a u.s. debate it's clear that the
European law particular on the privacy
side of things may end up being what
drives it because it seems like the
Europeans are being more restrictive on
privacy in some ways in a good way right
because summer because there may be a
lack of protection in some areas in the
US but I'm not confer you may have
different views I'm not confident this
is going to end up in a good place at
all I've often thought that if the
American taxpayer knew how much money is
spent in research for regulation that
they might have a very different view of
the roles of I obese I shared an IRB I
certainly was a patient advocate before
I went to medical school I certainly am
a believer in patients rights to privacy
but much of what goes on in that
discussion has to deal with protecting
the institution rather than protecting
the individual and it's really not about
communication and in
mation it's really about protecting
institutions I'll have something to say
about all of this later on but and I
wanted to ask a different question which
is something that to me that seems quite
fundamental I haven't actually heard
mentioned yet which is the notion of
cultural change so with this emergence
of the importance of data it seems that
there's a as a cost of time and energy
associated with that that and it's also
speaks to a different kind of
scholarship of valuing scholarship in a
different wave if you're expecting
investigators to spend more time helping
with the process of making data more
usable that sort of in a sense elevates
data the value of data within the realm
of scholarship and it needs to clearly
if that's going to happen that has to be
a give and take so there has to be
rewarded for that I'm interested in what
Yael thinks about that cultural shift
and have anything that's happening that
reflects that
I think it's discussion for everybody
I'm the reason it's difficult said the
sentence that caught my eye or the
phrase that comprise is quote what Yale
thanks and you know that they're there
are whatever some number of thousand
people at Yale and my guess is you have
a thousand different opinions on that I
think we're all struggling with this I
it's actually we talk these
preservations of data issues that Susan
mentioned and we the students coming
from the library's we've dealt with
thinking that the preservation of
information we've done I dia that that's
important in the humanities for hundreds
of years so our traditional view of the
libraries as a storing written text and
preserving written texts or in the case
of our libraries also support oaring
ancient pre- reptar text on which are
written in what are there is no they
play so these issues have been around
for libraries on the history and
humanities side for a very very long
time also in art history and so we're
seeing them spread we're seeing the same
issues now spreading into the into the
sciences I my gut feeling is that the is
there not that they're new issues in
that the scope is much bigger now but
they're not really new issues right the
idea that incredibly important to
preserve information and to make
information accessible to others and
with all the accompanying problems of
privacy and regulation that go with it I
think that in some sense they're just
the enlargement because if the date is
much bigger than the enlargement of
issues with we've been struggling with
for a long time I do that Susan this is
really Susan's area more than mine but
that that's that my gut feeling is it
again there isn't what Yael thinks but I
think that I think that this isn't quite
as new an issue as we're claiming it is
it's a it's a it's the same issue
written much larger I think the
perspective I'd add to that is I see an
interesting tension within the
humanities as the humanities moves
towards more data use and the digital
humanities are
merging there's a natural tension within
the humanities as to whether that is
good research and whether it is okay to
be a digital humanist and be accepted
within your discipline particularly when
your output might not be a book or an
article but may take a very different
form you may take a digital form so
there's an interesting tension on that
side of it and on the science and social
science side there is an interesting
tension around the burden of caring for
your data and and sharing it with others
and so in many ways I think they're all
sort of coming together around a similar
set of problems across all the
disciplines in a way in the past we had
seen ourselves in very different places
that for the humanists the end result
was the book and of course you saved all
of your copious notes of how you got to
and the footnotes identified everything
very very carefully now in the digital
humanities world how does that look like
how do you reference how do you point
back to so I think all the disciplines
are struggling with this new world where
you need to convey much more of the
underpinnings and how you convey those
underpinnings is sort of what we're
struggling with and then allowing
replication or reuse and so while I
think we look at it right now as a
burden as soon as we're on the other
side of the equation and benefit from
reusing someone's data that has been
really nicely documented curated
preserved and easily accessible we'll
start to see the value and in it and
start to internalize that value and
hopefully as institutions start to
recognize that that's an important part
of the dissemination process
so I'm a professor of sociology in the
school for stirring environmental
studies and I teach a course on or
teaching a course right now on Big Data
and one of the things that I'm having a
hard time with and I'm wondering if the
library or IT is going to help with is
just as important as the data are the
methods we used to analyze them and that
sort of thing I know that's not the
focus of the today but I'm wondering is
there going to be more are there going
to be more resources in terms of it when
I think of my students it would be nice
to be able to send them to some sort of
workshop and said of having to work with
each student individually on different
methods and things like that so some
sort of maybe intensive training or
opportunities like that on whether it's
like programming skills or working with
databases and so as we've been imagining
what the center for research computing
would look like we've been thinking that
one of the key things that they need to
do is not only create community and
bring people together that can share
methods and techniques but also provide
some other services from the center one
of which would be something like the
equivalent of application development or
programming support so someone who can
work with your students and with you and
with other researchers that you're
working with to help develop your code
that's one important thing and the other
thing that we realize should be part of
the mission of the center is is to
provide seminars workshops training so
that the infrastructure and the
technology that we're providing to you
you'll be able to leverage it the best
way possible so so the hope is that the
center will be providing that for you
going right back to the cyc the
committee to change the curriculum at
Yale which is more than a decade ago
we've been struggling with how to
coordinate better our earlier entry
level statistics classes and and one of
the struggles that was there then and I
hoped would have gone away by now it
hasn't is that different fields feel
very strongly about have very strong
disagreements about what are the basic
packages you
so in the social say my heir of the
social sciences we end up teaching our
students essentially boot camps on how
to use stata and we just think it's
doesn't a waste of time for them to
learn some of the packages that they
might learn in in the stance department
and the status apartment has similarly
strong views the other way so and these
are these are strong and difficult
social norms because it's frankly true
that in a my field if they don't know
stata they can't get a job so it'd be
nice to have a common standard across
the sciences statistics sanders and the
more quantity of Social Sciences but we
aren't there I don't actually what the
solution to this is I think some of it
needs to be boot camps in the relevant
fields where you learn these things I
don't particularly think you need to
have a whole semester's course on how to
use stay there for example it's really
just you know a couple of weeks to teach
people how to be an RA and teach people
how the necessary technique same with
saying some of these programming skills
but there is this a slate it's
unfortunate that we see this divergence
of what are the right packages because
really what you're talking about i think
is basic programming and the ability to
use a basic statistics passing package
you
I believe then we have wrapped up our
session please join me in thanking been
for coming here and sharing some time
with us today